social security joining us from Boston
is Robert Posen who is chairman of MF s
investment management he's also a former
member of the President Social Security
Commission mr. posed in an idea that you
have put forth regarding Social Security
has made a whole bunch of news in recent
days talk to us about it what are you
thinking about the plan what's your
proposal my proposal is something called
progressive indexing it's a way to slow
down the growth of benefits in a way
that protects the benefits of low-wage
workers who would stay exactly the same
under my plan slows the growth of high
wage workers and slows the growth a
little more over time and the rationale
for this plan is that high and middle
wage workers already get a lot of IRAs
and 401ks and have the tax benefits
associated with those programs but IRAs
and 401ks are virtually non-existent
below 25 thousand dollars a year in
earnings which is the level I use for
low-wage workers so to keep the total
retirement income package reasonable for
low-wage workers we need to treat them a
little better under Social Security and
because the high-end middle wage workers
have IRAs and 401ks they're looking at a
package of retirement benefits IRAs
401ks and Social Security so they can
afford to have a little slower growth in
Social Security benefits and they have
the tax advantages involved with the
private retirement program what sparked
you to come up with your idea and we do
know that you were at the White House
this week how did you actually propose
the plan well I first proposed the plan
in the New York Times a few years ago
and then I published a piece in The
Economist in January and I published
another piece this week in Wall Street
Journal in which I elaborated various
aspects of it
this is a modification of one of the
models that was in the President's
Commission and the President's
Commission one of the proposals that was
discussed was going completely from
what's called wage indexing to price
indexing
that makes the system very solvent but
it creates a lot of problems for
low-wage workers so the more I thought
about it the best solution seemed to be
to help low wage workers by not changing
the indexing for their wage benefits but
taking into account that higher wage
workers had private IRAs and 401ks
slowing down the growth of their
benefits a little so that's how it came
about here's a look at your piece from
The Wall Street Journal from Tuesday by
Robert posed in a progressive solution
for Social Security personal retirement
accounts don't have to increase debt mr.
president we'll take a look at a quick
clip of President Bush from his news
conference yesterday he mentioned your
name and then we'll talk about it okay
sure a David there's some interesting
ideas and up there one of the
interesting ideas was by there's pelo by
the a Democrat economist named of posen
he came to visit the White House didn't
see me but came to toss some interesting
ideas that talking about making sure the
system was progressive we're open for
ideas and I look I can understand why
people say make force the president to
either negotiate with himself or lay out
his own bill I want to work with members
of both political parties what do you
make of that reaction well I I'm glad to
hear that the president is interested in
my plan I was at the White House on
Tuesday I met with a number of the
people who are his point people in the
area of Social Security I think the
president is open to a broad range of
plans but so far the debate has been
focused almost entirely on personal
accounts whether you like them or not
that maximizes the ideological conflict
and I think has really put the spotlight
on the desert the personal accounts of
the part that politically people are
selling but the main point here is the
spinach the main point is to get the
system solvent if we can come up with a
plan hopefully a bipartisan plan that
makes the system solvent then we can
talk about what sort of sweeteners or
desserts you would attach in a package
to sell the plant robert posin is
joining us from Boston here are the
numbers to call if you want to take part
in this conversation about social
security if
few uh support Democrats here is your
number 202 737 triple 0 2 if you support
President Bush it's 2 o-two 737 triple 0
1 and if you support others 202 6 to 8 0
to 0-5 Robert posin was a member of the
president's Social Security Commission
2001 and 2002 he mentioned that you are
a Democrat sir are you one of those who
thinks the system is in crisis or or
just needs some type of fix you know get
us into that debate that we've been
having here in Washington what's your
view
why don't I don't think the Social
Security system is in crisis today but
it has a serious problem and it's
predictably will be in crisis starting
around the year 2020 and going forward
and I believe that when you have a
system that is not yet in crisis but you
know over the next few decades we'll be
in crisis the best thing to do is act
early act in a moderate way and to
prevent the crisis so I think if we do
something over the next few years we can
prevent the crisis we're not in a crisis
now and that's the good part but the
fact that we're not in a crisis doesn't
mean we should do nothing because if we
do nothing we will be in a crisis later
years aside from the president's
reaction mr. posle what other kind of
reaction have you gotten from here in
Washington and elsewhere to your
proposal well generally I've gotten a
very good reaction people like the idea
of progressive indexing because I think
most people feel that the key to Social
Security is to provide an income floor
for the low-wage workers and they're
primarily dependent on Social Security
they don't really have a lot of other
retirement income so if you can modify
the system to make it solvent and my
proposal does make it solvent then and
protect this group of people then you've
achieved the primary goal the real
question then comes how do you slow the
growth in a moderate way for hire and
medium workers and leave them in a
position where they think it's
reasonable and that's why I've tried to
put together what's happening in the IRA
in the 401k market as well as social
security if you look at this is only a
social security issue
then you're neglecting the fact that
most people view their retirement income
as coming from many sources when you
start to view it more realistically then
you can see that the government is
actually subsidizing IRAs and 401ks and
those subsidies are going to higher and
middle wage workers so they even out the
government subsidies you've got to treat
low-wage workers a little better under
Social Security calls now for Robert
Posen we're talking Social Security from
renko Porto Rico good morning good
morning I'm very curious well thank you
for your plan is extremely interesting
for my personal point of view about
helping the lower class work because
I've benefited from 403b
individual IRA thanks mr. Posen yeah
were you able to catch all the yeah I
heard the question the question was
where he likes the plan where's the
resistance gonna come from right I think
first of all you just have at the moment
a sort of ideological impasse on certain
levels with the president pushing
personal accounts ownership society and
some Democrats saying they're just
against it ideologically so the first
thing we have to do is get around all
these ideological issues and start
talking about numbers and start talking
about actual people and actual benefits
the second thing I think is under my
plan in Social Security you slow down
the growth of benefits of high wage of
middle wage workers now it's they are
still growing the Social Security
benefits are still growing for the
middle and higher wage workers but
they're growing less than some
theoretical schedule that existed in the
sky so there will be people who will say
this is a benefit cut we were entitled
to some larger number and even though
we're a higher earner or middle earner
we're gonna get a little less my view is
twofold one is we have to explain to
these people there is no legal
entitlement to this schedule up in the
sky and we can't afford it and
second of all that we have to look at
the total government support for
retirement programs and if we do that we
can see that most of the tax benefits
most of the tax advantages that the
government is financing are going to the
middle and higher earners for IRAs and
401ks and so if we look at the total
government support picture my plan puts
every income group in a relatively
neutral position let's take a call from
glen allen illinois good morning to you
hi hi I had a question about what
happened in 1983 I'm about at the end of
the baby boom and we were told that
because of the baby boom we were going
to have to pre-fund our own retirement
by putting additional money into Social
Security so here the hugest part of the
population has put extra money into
Social Security over the last 20 years
and I'm wondering why that didn't work
mr. posin well yeah I think it's a it's
a good question and there are a lot of
answers one the main answer is that we
have been running a surplus on a
year-to-year basis for Social Security
for now 20 years unfortunately Congress
didn't take that money and invest it in
the sense that you and I would think of
investing is putting it into a
segregated trust fund which invested in
whether it be bonds or stocks or
anything instead that money was
basically spent in the expenditure
process by Congress and what it gave the
trust fund was an IOU a special Treasury
now the only way those Treasuries can be
redeemed if you go to Congress and
Congress has to either borrow money or
cut expenditures in other areas so
unfortunately while this theme this this
plan in theory should have worked in the
sense that we had this big surplus none
of that surplus was really invested in
the traditional sense and I think for
those people who feel going forward what
should we learn from this we should
learn for this that we should have some
real advance funding whether it be in
personal accounts or in a segregated
collective trust fund so that the monies
that are going to Social Security aren't
just mixed up with the rest of the
budget and it's too tempting for
Congress
to spend that money I think another
thing is at the time in eighteen 1983
there were economists who said that
using wage indexing rather than price
indexing was going to be very expensive
in the long run and we probably couldn't
afford it unfortunately those people who
made those warnings weren't heated at
the time and we have seen that the use
of wage indexing for the calculation of
initial benefits has indeed turned out
to be much more expensive than we
anticipated so I'm sorry but those are
the two main reasons why the plan in
1983 turned out not to be a permanent
solution talk to us more mister
president about the the personal
accounts to what extent what personal
accounts be some type of fix to to shore
up the system and give it health versus
all the other ideas out there including
yours yeah personal accounts is it not
itself a solution to Social Security
personal accounts are to dessert what we
need to do is look at the spinach the
spinach is making the system solvent my
approach makes the system solvent you
could do other things like raising
retirement age the raising retirement
age is very unpopular politically and
raises issues about physical labor for
lots of workers who are on construction
or on assembly lines so once you have a
proposal that has support for making the
system solvent then someone is going to
lose some benefits gonna have slower
growing benefits under that proposal and
then you have to figure out what's the
sweetener to put in the package to make
it attractive to the voters into
Congress personal accounts is is quite a
good sweetener because it does two
things it appeals to the higher and
middle wage workers some of whom would
very much like to take two or three
percent of their FICA taxes and put it
in a personal account and second of all
hopefully they would get a higher return
in the personal account than they got in
Social Security so it helped them earn
back some of their slower-growing
benefits under the solvency fix but I
should emphasize that progressive
indexing can be put together with all
sorts of other proposals it does not
have to go with personal accounts it can
go for instance with enhanced credits
for IRAs
it can go with the various benefit
reforms that people have talked about
for divorcees and widows so again if you
can get the solvency problem solved then
you can go and attach a variety of
different sweeteners personal accounts
perfectly reasonable one but there are
others also North Beach Maryland thank
you for waiting you're on with Robert
Posen good morning I disagree I'm 27
years old and I am concerned about
social security in the future but I
don't understand how personal accounts
can help anyone to be honest with you
except the rich and the reason just
being is I've always been told if you
have more money in a big sorry more
money in a big pot that there's going to
be more money earned an interest which
you know having more money I mean I also
had a question to be out if the bonds
that we have now if they're cashed out
regularly and reinvested I wanted to
know if that if that was the case as
well but I understand what you say an
individualized counts are the topping
which I understand somewhat but it's
kind of you have to take that in effect
if we're gonna go more in debt for it
thanks mr. Posen well you've asked the
number of questions altogether let me
just say one when we get you know in
about a decade to the point where we're
gonna have to redeem all those bonds
unfortunately we're not going to be able
to reinvest that money we're gonna have
to spend it by putting out checks for
retirement benefits so when Congress
redeems those bonds even if it goes in
issues public debt or cuts expenditures
we're not going to be able to reinvest
the money the second thing is yes if you
have a bigger pool you'll you'll earn
more interest the question is how much
of that interest accrues to which people
and the return on Social Security is
unfortunately for people at where 27 is
quite low it's really below 3% a year
real which means after inflation so if
you keep the money in the big pot and
the big pot continues to be in Treasury
you're probably going to make about 3%
after inflation if you have a system
that slows the growth of traditional
benefits
gives you a chance to put two or three
percent of your FICA taxes in a personal
account and you put in a conservative
balanced account which would have say
sixty percent in an S&P 500 index fund
and forty percent in a high-grade bond
fund your chances of making over five
percent in that account are about 87
percent and your chances of making over
four percent are about 98 percent now
there's nothing guaranteed but what I'm
trying to explain is that the return of
that big pool is quite low and if you
have personal accounts you'd have a
little better chance quite a bit better
chance of earning some of that slower
growth back so I hope those are
reasonable answers to the questions that
were given let's get another question
from Rockford Illinois this time welcome
to the program
yeah I have a question um I'm I am I
missing something here or I can't
understand how the president is pushing
an idea like this when he has no idea
itself what you know to push I don't
ever remember asking the President to
touch my Social Security do you have a
comment well I think the President did
raise in his electoral campaign the
issues that many economists the many
politicians have been grappling with for
years that while were not in a crisis
now were predictably in a crisis in a
decade or two decades and so he did
raise the issue that we should do
something I think the president has not
come out with a plan instead he's been
emphasizing this personal accounts
aspect and as I said before I think it's
unfortunate because he's concentrating
on the desert and maximizing ideological
conflict I think if he came out and we
had a discussion about what reasonably
we could do to improve the solvency of
Social Security that would get a more
bipartisan of flavor to the discussion I
think that it is the president's job to
look to the future it's the job of every
president to deal with the major issues
that are facing the country to show
leadership and I think in this restrict
respect President Bush is showing
leadership Social Security is a serious
problem it's one that we should start
to deal with gradually now and it takes
leadership from the president I think
what you're really seeing is the
president doesn't come up with a
particular plan because this is part of
the political back-and-forth he doesn't
want to come up with a plan because then
he feels that Democrats will shoot at
him the Democrats feel that they don't
have to come up with a plan because
they're not the president so at the
moment you have a bit of a games playing
sort of atmosphere and I'd like to see
that shifted away from the ideological
away from the games playing and more to
a serious discussion on the numbers of
solvency for Social Security we are
talking with Robert Posen who was up in
Boston he is chairman of MF s investment
management it's a former member of the
president Social Security Commission and
you are featured in The Wall Street
Journal today this piece by Jackie
Calmes the headline says new wrinkle on
Social Security
progressive indexing may help Bush
broker a compromise there's a sketch of
you here mr. Posen and just to help us
out since this can be tough to follow
repeat for us again what your plan is
progressive indexing how would it work
let's take a step back most people think
that Social Security is increased
gradually as prices going up the
Consumer Price Index and this is true
after retirement these are what are the
cost-of-living adjustments however at
the time of your initial Social Security
benefits the time we calculate that
Social Security now takes the average
career earnings that you have and then
increases that amount by the percentage
increase in wages over your lifetime not
over-bright not prices over your
lifetime this is the difference between
wage indexing and price indexing of
initial benefits now it turns out that
if today we did nothing but change
everyone from wage to price indexing of
their initial benefits we would actually
close a hundred percent of the long-term
deficit of Social Security which is
about three point eight trillion and
present value so the question is why
don't we do this and the answer is I
believe that it would really be
devastating to low wage workers because
they would be getting what's called a
lower
replacement ratio the amount of their
benefits from Social Security relative
to their pre-retirement income would go
down and these people have no IRAs they
have no 401ks so they're entirely
dependent on Social Security and if
their replacement ratio goes down for
Social Security they're really in a fix
when it comes to their retirement by
contrast if we look at a person over
$100,000 they have very many sources of
retirement income personal savings IRAs
401ks or 401 or 403b s so for them they
can afford a slower growth in their
Social Security benefits since they're
getting retirement benefits from many
other sources and this is an important
point this is not just welfare for the
poor the tax benefits that go into these
retirement and 401k IRA programs run
into the billions there are over fifty
or sixty billion dollars a year so there
already is a lot of government subsidy
going to higher and middle wage workers
to support their 401ks and IRAs and
therefore it is reasonable and fair to
treat low wage workers a little better
allowing them to stay on wage indexing
of their initial benefits to even out
government support for retirement income
get back to those calls Westfield New
Jersey thanks for waiting hi hello I
wanted to say Westfield was that one of
the locations that President Bush came
to have a national conversation Mike
Ferguson posted him and I was happy to
be present at that presentation let me
ask you how was it that you became
invited what was the process well my 14
year old son James has worked for
congressman Ferguson and he was offered
the chance to have some tickets
gotcha what do you think about all this
well first of all James has a question
and that is how would a guest worker
program work with contributing to the
Social Security base and also I have a
question how would you think of
integrating some type of vocational
retraining
for those receiving Social Security
Disability that may be able to do some
kind of work mr. po I'm the question of
guest workers I believe that you're
referring to a program that some people
have discussed about allowing a limited
form of immigration from other countries
in which people would come in they would
pay Social Security and then some of the
Social Security tax would go back with
them to their to their home country but
in order to help our system some of it
would have to stay here so to make a
guest worker program positive for Social
Security you would have to have a
situation where say a worker came from
Honduras or worker came from Russia they
stayed here for 10 years they paid into
Social Security and then half or
two-thirds would go back with them for
retirement but the Social Security
system would keep one half or one third
that's surely a way in which you would
help Social Security solvency a little
but I think we shouldn't get carried
away with it because given the national
security issues and other things
involved with immigration I don't think
it's reasonable to think that we're
gonna talk more than maybe a hundred
thousand two hundred thousand workers a
year in that sort of program and as I
said we'd have to give some substantial
amount substantial amounts back to these
people when they left so we're talking
about a modest step in the right
direction but I emphasize modest now as
to people with disabilities this is a
very good question and it's a it's a
real problem for Social Security and as
we move the retirement age back we have
to realize that while a lot of people
are now knowledge workers there are
people who still work construction there
are people who are still on factory
lines and for them as they get older the
idea of doing physical labor is going to
be quite challenging to the extent that
we can retrain them in jobs where they
wouldn't have to be so physical where
they could use more of a knowledge base
that would be great it would be great
for them it'd be great for the Social
Security system which pays out a lot in
disability whether that retraining is
realistic I think has to be judged on a
my case basis some people do have the
educational background where they could
make the switch for other people
especially at very in ages above 60
making that sort of total retraining may
not be a realistic possibility also it
depends on what level of disability they
have obviously if it's a situation where
somebody has a bad leg then they can
easily retrain for a desk job but if
some people have a more serious illness
ms or something like that then it may
not be realistic to think of them as
retraining into any job so I just think
this is the sort of good idea it just
has to be applied in a sensible
case-by-case basis not sure if you had a
chance to read it yet mr. Posen but
there's a piece in the Boston Globe
today about your plan and it's a piece
by Charles Stein the headline says Posen
Social Security fix sparks buzz plan
would combine investment accounts
selective benefit cuts one of the read
just part of the back end of this piece
there's a David John with Heritage
Foundation who says Democrats are cool
to the plan right now because it
includes private accounts still he
suggests some Democratic moderates might
be willing to back a version of Poe's
ins scheme down the road they used the
word scheme their liberal economists
don't see the plans appeal there's a
quote here from an Ellen auerbach an
economist at Cal Berkeley he calls it
bush light what do you think well in the
Washington Post they said we think a
better name for this is Bush smart
rather than Bush light so of course I'd
like to push smart better than Bush
light but I think that there are two
things that are incorrect about that
criticism one is the assumption is that
progressive indexing can only be matched
with the sweetener of carve-out personal
accounts the ones the type of ones the
president is talking about I've made it
very clear that progressive indexing can
be combined with other sorts of
sweeteners one it would be an add-on
type of account an enhancement of the
tax credits that go for IRAs
and there are a variety of different
things that be combined with progressive
indexing so I think for those
people who say that progressive indexing
can only be linked to carve out personal
accounts they're just plain wrong the
second thing is that you know I believe
that there are Democrats that are
flexible on this issue but if this is
put as an ideological question if this
is done as well ownership a society
versus the traditional Social Security
benefits you're almost making it a very
ideological battle and one where people
don't feel comfortable weighing in so
again if we could get back to solvency
and really talk about issues that have
to do with solvency progressive indexing
is a good way in my view to approach
solvency it's not bush light it stands
on its own
maghreb indexing first in the new york
times several years ago and did not
attach it to personal accounts personal
accounts is a variant that I developed
when listening to the president realized
that this was something he wanted to do
and tried to think about how could you
take the concerns about low-wage workers
and the desires of certain high wage
workers to have personal accounts and
meld them together but this melding is
just one form of progressive indexing
and there are a variety of other forms
that are possible back to the phone's
Baton Rouge Louisiana your honor with
Robert Posen hi there good morning
morning I come to you as a man whose
401k was completely almost completely
wiped out in the late 90s I think we
ought to do is quit running the
government on the backs of the working
poor and get the rich people to pay
their fair share I think this is only
reasonable they've been running our
they've been paying for the government
with our pensions and this is exactly
what's going on I think they ought to
pay back the notes they gave to our
pension and then the the what do you
call it the the problem will just simply
go away all right posing you know I I'm
not exactly sure what happened to your
401k it sounds like it was a very bad
experience and I'm sorry about that but
I
one of the things that we tried to do in
the President's Commission one of the
things I do in my plan is to have a very
low risk type of investment I don't
think we should have in Social Security
the broad range of investments that we
have in many 401k plans including
employer stock including risky notes or
in IRAs under my plan
everyone presumptively would go into a
balanced account compose sixty percent
of a broad-based stock index fund and
forty percent of a broad-based
high-quality bond fund if you look at
that sort of account over thirty
thirty-five years it consistently
returns a little over eight percent
before inflation and if you take off
three percentage points for inflation
over five percent and the reason it does
it is because it's long-term consistent
investing it's dollar cost averaging yes
there are down years in the stock market
there were 13 down years between 1950
and 2004 but if you were investing over
a 35-year period in a broad-based index
and not in individual stocks that tends
to even out the set another thing is out
of those 13 years that the stock market
was down 12 of those years the bond
market was up so if you have a balanced
portfolio of stocks and bonds it tends
to be much less volatile so if we're
gonna do that sort of investing I
believe that we ought to do it in a
conservative manner as to whether rich
people should pay their fair share I
think you can argue about this left and
right what I'm trying to do is say let's
look at the total government support for
retirement income a lot of that
government tax subsidy in the IRAs and
401ks is now going to higher income
people and therefore their Social
Security benefits should slow have a
slower growth than lower wage workers
because the lower wage workers are not
getting most of the tax benefits from
IRAs and 401ks so I don't view this as
sucking the rich I view this as evening
out government support providing a
relatively neutral position of the
government relative to income groups
but to do that given the practical
context I think you have to treat
low-wage workers a little better in
terms of social security we have a
caller from Sterling Virginia for Robert
Posen hey there supposin hi how you done
to me it seems like most of the people
on the left their main focus is on
saving a government program and the
people on the right their main focus is
securing the financial foundation of our
seniors now to me I don't see why you
know there should be a fight that's
wasn't it too but whatever you hear the
Democrats talk on the floor of the
Senate or you know get in front of a
camera it's all about saving Social
Security whatever you hear the
Republicans talk it's all about making
sure the individual has enough money to
secure their financial freedom when
they're in their outer years and can no
longer be productive I don't see where
there's an argument about this
personally I think if you want to really
have ownership of Social Security you
need to do it this way have it to where
an individual can tap into their social
security fund way before the retirement
age say like when they get laid off
instead of you know destroying their
credit and you know all their bills
never being paid filing bankruptcy let
them tap into say $20,000 of their
social security fund every five years
with say a five percent penalty for
early withdrawal like if they get 20
grand actual and getting 19 and a
thousand is deducted from their fund and
then they can you know they can keep
making their payments they can secure
their credit score which is the true
you know catalyst for financial freedom
and then they can purchase like it's
maybe even first-time homebuyers that
are in lower income brackets can take
that 20,000 put it towards the purchase
of a home and that is their retirement
of owning your own home is the best
retirement fund you could ever get into
thanks mister posin well I tend to agree
that if you listen to Democrats and
Republicans they there there is
different language used than you would
think that they could come together but
I think what it really has to do with
is how each party views the way in which
you get to retirement income the
Democrats tend to like the traditional
Social Security program which is a
scheduled benefit like a defined benefit
plan in which there is no funding of an
individual account there is no
investment in any securities the
Republicans believe that you aren't
getting enough return out of your social
security investments because Congress as
I mentioned before hasn't really
invested the money and they think that
this sort of advanced funding is the
only way to go I think that those
aspects of the system and the
perspectives on that sort of are
maximizing the ideological differences
between the parties I think both parties
share the goal of trying to have a more
solvent system and when you get down to
the solvency of the system you have to
start talking about what's going to
happen to benefits what's going to
happen to retirement age what's going to
happen to revenues and if there were a
more pragmatic discussion on solvency I
believe that you'd have more coming
together of the parties as to your point
about having money taken out of Social
Security before retirement I'm afraid I
don't really agree with that we now
allow people to take money out of before
retirement in IRAs and 401ks but I think
we've found that some people take so
much money out then when it comes to the
time of retirement they don't have
enough now of course if they take their
money out and they invest it in a good
house and it appreciates well that's
great but we've seen many people take
money out before retirement and spend it
on various different things and then
when they get to retirement they don't
have enough money to live on and I think
that the ultimate goal the primary goal
of Social Security has to be to make
sure that everyone has a floor of
retirement income at that time and so I
believe that while it's okay to have
other programs to help the unemployed
and I would encourage them it's okay to
have and we do have programs to
encourage homebuyers you can't have
withdrawals from your IRAs and 401ks or
this purpose is
that's the social security I believe
that you really should leave it alone
until you retire so it's there so it's
make sure it's there
you know everyone it's hard to predict
for everyone where you're gonna be when
you're 65 so I think it's very important
that we keep that pot available just for
retirement Belpre Ohio you're on the air
with Robert Posen we're talking Social
Security good morning good morning mr.
Poe's anything thanks for taking my call
and I'm wondering when exactly was the
Social Security surplus tapped into and
why under which administration or was
there particularly administration and we
always hear the term locked box and I
thought this had applied to protecting
that Social Security surplus and I'm
also wondering you know I'm a single
mother of three making twenty seven
thousand a year I've never asked the
state or federal government for anything
in my whole life but I can't afford
health care for my children I can't even
afford catastrophic health care aren't
there more immediate issues right now to
be dealing with for the Bush
administration and for our Congress I
mean it just seems like a more immediate
crisis to be dealing with Thanks I
wanted to begin with the surplus
question yeah I would say this is
definitely a nonpartisan issue
Republican and Democratic
administrations in fact every president
we've had since 1983 has spent the
surplus and has given a special Treasury
I owe used to the trust fund the lockbox
was invoked for I think a total of about
six months beside having very good jokes
on Saturday Night Live it really never
came into existence unfortunately the
money never was locked up and the
lockbox I guess you would have to say is
empty as to the the relative merits of
addressing the social security versus
healthcare issues I I tend to agree that
health care is probably a more difficult
problem it's a it's a it's a it's a
major problem and it's surely one we
have to deal with but I think that if
you try to deal with health care which
is going to be a problem over the next
20 years
when you
you have not solved Social Security
you're going to be dealing with a very
large problem health care and a large
problem Social Security in Social
Security we actually have a chance to
fix this now
if we do some reasonable things now over
the next five to ten years we can start
moving in the right direction and so in
the out years we won't have this
albatross a lot on our back while we're
trying to deal with the very difficult
issues of health care so I don't view
them as mutually exclusive
I think it's an intelligent thing to try
to deal with the problem before it's a
crisis in a way that you can put it to
bed and then have the resources and the
time to tackle the healthcare problem
which probably as you say is going to be
something that may be more difficult
than social security I think they're
they're both problems that have to be
dealt with and I'd like to see us deal
with social security first get that off
the table and then concentrate on health
care and before we go mr. posed and back
to that subhead to the wall of the Wall
Street Journal piece today progressive
indexing your idea here may help Bush
broker a compromise what do you think do
you think this could be it
something that could propel this debate
forward well I think that progressive
indexing is an idea that appeals to
Democrats as well as Republicans because
its first and highest priority is to
protect low-wage workers like the woman
who was just on it was making twenty
seven thousand dollars a year but I
don't believe that progressive indexing
alone is going to be enough to get both
parties together I think it's critical
that we stop talking about the desert
personal accounts we stop talking about
this in a very ideological way and that
we start talking about solvency once we
start talking about solvency then I
think the parties will start to have
good discussions and let's leave as a
secondary question what will be the
sweeteners what will be the desserts
that will be packaged with any solvency
solution obviously President Bush wants
to have his form of personal accounts
there are a lot of other ideas that are
around we can have a reasonable
discussion about that sweetener about
personal accounts or add-on
carve-out accounts once we address the
solvency problem but if we aren't if we
don't put the solvency a question first
if we don't have that discussion which I
believe can be a bipartisan discussion
first then we're never going to get to
those other questions instead we're just
going to get embroiled as unfortunately
we have with a bit of ideological debate
a bit of stalemate and so I believe it's
not just progressive indexing that's the
key to getting this debate restarted
it's also getting to solvency as the
main focus if we can do solvency and
focus on that progressive indexing as a
reasonable approach I'm sure there are
other reasonable approaches that's the
way to get the debate going robert Posen
is chairman of MF s investment
management also a former member of the
president's Social Security Commission
back in 2001 and to joining us from
Boston thanks a lot for your time
thank you for having me